so guys if you watched my video earlier
we've got some very important news that
could see Andrew Tate and Tristan
released very soon we find out the
decision over the next two days whether
each proverb will be released and it
says in Oracle the lawyers for the two
brothers noted that none of these
reasons to be released have anything to
do with medical reasons as rumors were
stating it says as we know Andrew Tate
and Tristan have always maintained
different Avenues of communication and
there is no evidence against them and
they are innocent as what she had said
but an important note on there was I
would like to point out that these
requests as well as previous ones do not
have as the object a replacement of
preventative measure on the basis of
medical reasons the Millionaire's lawyer
said has come out in a recent interview
the lawyer cannot even speak to them
without being traced right now it's
better for them to be out and go through
this case than it is then Behind Bars
because it's literally impossible to
even communicate with them the irony
that they have a woman lawyer but
they're the biggest misogynist ever I
don't know do you think they're gonna
get released I doubt it fortunately I
have no idea
the reason that it you know this is hard
this is so difficult to discuss is
because it's Romanian law we can't even
look up the law you know and understand
it the way we could in the U.S where we
could at least make heads or tails and
make a good educated guess no idea what
they're like not only do I not
understand the law I don't have any
precedent I don't know how they
typically treat their Prisoners the only
thing I know is the one thing that we've
said we know which is that they can just
keep people without charging them for up
to six months in 30-day increments which
is astonishing and horrible and scary
that's some old world right there I
can just it's been almost three months
right they went in December so yeah just
before New Year's almost three months
that's that's actually yeah I
mean this is this is like medieval
I couldn't imagine if I if I was just
locked up for months over something I
didn't do that's crazy like I I can't I
who knows what it's going to be like
they did it and they don't have and they
don't have any evidence and they haven't
pressed charges and you're just locked
up and they may not be able to ever
prove that you did anything what do you
even do are there reparations for that
are we just going to give them to the
black people
oh with them it's recorded always so
imagine you're the lawyer of somebody
that you're defending in any
conversation you're having with them the
calls are being recorded what can you
talk to your client about think about
what I just said right there the lawyer
can't talk to the client without it
being recorded and can't even go there
face to face to see them she's called
the embassy of Romania
to say hey can you help me out here to
go talk to this guy because he's also
got a U.S citizenship nope we're not
doing nothing I mean it's it's it's very
problematic and by the way since April
of last year
they could we got Brittany grimer's ass
out can't get Pub G out you kidding me
it's a youth that's some bull
please that's some somebody
that has been accused of misogyny do you
think that the Biden Administration is
going to spend any time whatsoever
trying to get him out when all the what
the to get the feminists and the men
dresses women who pretend to be
feminists descending on the White House
yeah this is just no yeah but the whole
the whole pendulum is swinging right
imagine he Biden did that because the
thing is would be like think about it
from a chess perspective like if Trump
runs again against Biden the libtards
are gonna vote for Biden regardless
because they hate Trump but if Biden
gets top G out then he might gain some
some other people since the pendulum's
swinging so far right right now
yeah he's not no top G getting out of
jail I imagine was watching him and he
could have seen that and been like oh
that's a good idea you know what I bet
he is because he's not doing his job and
he's certainly not studying up on things
like economic policy and the law so he
probably is just watching us on YouTube
eating ice cream chocolate chip
well that was my that was my thought
process is that he's watching this but
then you just ruined it you just blew up
my point it doesn't matter he didn't
understand the exchange anyway it's fine
all right come on let's keep going to
rest the Tates uh would allegedly
whatever they were talking because
they've been investigating this for a
while since the vice did their story
but they decided to do it two days after
he called that Greta thundberg kind of
weird
you could have done it for seven eight
months but you waited eight months to do
it why why now all of a sudden you could
have rated it two months ago what what
is this video that's when he got
arrested was after he he made the Greta
Thunderbird oh okay oh it's because the
pizza was never about the pizza what
made you all of a sudden wanted how come
you didn't do it in September so yeah
one step possibly even on a home arrest
like the women were going to be released
on at least elua can communicate and
actually help them beat this case
properly without having everything they
talk about used against them once again
because they're talking from behind bars
the main reasons that she's putting
forward is through with their family and
their children then being outside to
support them they should be able to go
through this and wait to go to an actual
trial and be found guilty before
spending time by him boss but I'll keep
you guys posted on the decisions
tomorrow stay tuned to the channel by
leaving a like And subscribe with
another funny picture I was watching
Tate confidentials their Vlogs are so
funny that's exactly what I want to do
is just get super rich and make it hit
confidentials
I don't know what that is maybe we'll
watch one it's just it's just they just
vlogged their life where they were just
going around doing dumb and they
just had a guy well their cousin Luke
recording so it's basically just a
homemade reality show yeah but it's
actual reality it's them just shooting
going out driving cars it's
hilarious all right make sure to like
subscribe follow me on Instagram join my
Discord for free and I'll see you later
[Music]
good